We begin this hour in Ukraine
where Russian forces continue
to be sent in wave after wave
to try and overwhelm Ukrainian
defenders in the city a bucket.
The world --
is why this battle has been
described as a me grinder.
Small Russian advances have
come with a staggering loss of
life, and while many have
questioned the strategic value
of what's left of the city,
both sides have doubled down on
their commitment to control it.
This video posted on social
media, appears to show
Ukrainian combat vehicle coming
under fire from fighters with
the Russian Wagner mercenary
group.
Elsewhere, you can in forces
have been able to hold their
defensive lines.
This video appears to show
Russian shoulders in retreat
from the cities of skirts.
Russia claims to have captured,
around bakhmut, and the Russian
defense minister says the
victory here will open the way
to further invest's is in
eastern Ukraine.
There is no doubt this battle
has become a symbolic one.
, But what other strategic
value?
President volodymyr zelenskyy
spoke with CNN about the
decision to continue defending
his city.
This is technical for.
As we understand that after
Buckingham, they could go
further, they could go to
kramatorsk, to sloviansk, it
would be an open road for the
Russians after bakhmut to other
towns in Ukraine in the donetsk
direction in the east of
Ukraine.
Zelenskyy also reacted to
disturbing video released on
social media showing an unarmed
Ukrainian soldier being
executed.
He, says the video shows
Russia's attitude towards
prisoners of war, saying that
they do not have any laws, nor
did they respect anything.
CNN's Melissa bell has more
details now but we have a
warning, some viewers may find
the images they're about to see
disturbing.
Glory to Ukraine.
Where his last words.
Timothy sugar was his name.
His courage and his silhouette
made iconic, overnight, by his
brutal execution.
An officer from his brigade
telling CNN that his death will
not go unpunished.
We [speaking non-english]
[Sound of artillery]
[Speaking non-english]
The fate of bakhmut, still in
the balance.
With dozens more attacks to the
north of the besieged city and
heavy losses to the Russian
side, say Ukrainian
authorities.
But, efforts to encircle
bakhmut praised by the Russian
defense minister after an
unusual trip to the soldiers in
the occupied territories of
Ukraine.
We >> Translator: The city is
an important defensive for
Ukrainian troops in donbas.
Taking it under control will
allow for their offensive
actions, deep into the offense
of the armed forces of Ukraine.
>> The town also at the heart
of a tussle between the Russian
army and Wagner.
The mercenary group planting
its flag closer to the center
of bakhmut we.
Much of the fighting, now,
speak to streets, soldier to
soldier.
As civilians cower in their
basements, fewer than 4000, now,
say Ukraine and authorities,
including 30 children.
The ferocity of the artillery
and mortar fire that continue
to pound the city, making it
hard, even for soldiers to get
out.
And, as Moscow closes, in more
claims of so-called Ukrainian
terrorist activities will
staunch Marc --
Alexander lukashenko,
announcing the capture of a
Ukrainian Russian nationals
accused of trying to sabotage a
Russian surveillance plane at
immense airfield, without
presenting further evidence.
[Speaking non-english]
We >> Translator: Identified
and detained him.
Today, more than 20 accomplices
who are on the controllers have
been detained.
>> Only last week, Moscow
accused Ukrainian saboteurs of
opening fire on civilians
inside of Russia.
We but even as the war widens,
all eyes are very much on
bakhmut and whether this symbol
of Ukrainian resilience will
finally fall, even as a new one
is born.
Melissa bell, CNN, Kyiv.
Processor Matthew Smith this
director of international
affairs of the university of
New Haven.
He's an expert on defense and
intelligence Russia Ukraine and
U.S. Foreign policy.
Welcome back from Kyiv, glad
you're with us.
>> My pleasure, thank you.
>> Okay, so, on this question
is but not worth the blood
being spilled?
We just heard from the
president of Ukraine, he said
that if the city falls, it
could open the wave for the
Russians to go to kramatorsk, a
sloviansk, an open the roads to
other towns in the east of
Ukraine.
For the most, part the fall of
any city would leave the --
but the U.S. Secretary of
defense, Lloyd Austin, told
defense on Monday that the
Ukrainians could reposition to
the west of bakhmut to terrain
that was defensible and he
added this.
>> I would not view that as an
operational or strategic
setback.
I think that it is more a
symbolic value that is
strategic and operational
value.
So the fall of bakhmut won't
necessarily mean that the
Russians are and have changed
the title of the site.
I, mean I think it will
continue to be contested.
>> So, why is this being talked
about, slowly in terms of
either stand-your-ground or do
a full withdrawal are full
retreat, this is not a binary
choice, there are other options
here.
>> Well, first of, all you
still have to give respect to
the commander-in-chief but the
Ukrainian armed forces, if our
president would have said --
is a strategic importance --
the question, is where does he
get that point, from?
Wright is bucking would
strategically important because
of where it is on the map.
And general Austin correct
about, that would just to say
that you loose puck, mood
there's a fallback position
where you can still defend
from.
I think clearly it is or is it
important for a third reason.
Because, it's essentially a
trap to keep Russians and to
get Russians to expand
ammunition in.
And to extend vehicles --
so that whatever happens with
the color of the, math in a few,
days the Russians would've lost
for more the Ukrainians and
that is what makes a
strategically important.
>> Okay, so that in, mind after
the recent, visit Michael
Cochrane, a U.S. Based defense
analyst posted on Twitter that
the defense buckled achieved a
great deal, expanding Russian
man power and ammunition but
strategies can reach a point of
diminishing returns.
, And given Ukraine is trying
to house resources for
offensives --
it couldn't be the success of a
more important operation.
According to Kaufman, Ukrainian
forces received heavy forces on
par with the Russians.
, So could both sides be
putting their overall war dolls
in doubt here?
>> Well, it's always the
possibility that both sides are
wrong, both sides are sort of
being driven by the emotions
and not by the rational reasons
in this position.
, But I think what you have to
recognize is that Ukraine is
gearing, up it's getting
counteroffensive --
--
he claims about 40% --
western countries are
intensifying the supply an army
Terry military hard work in
Ukraine, they are training
programs for you cleaning army
personnel --
, however nato support of the
Kyiv regime does not translate
into success in Ukraine for the
battlefield --
on the contrary, we observe and
increase for the losses, but
the Ukrainian armed forces.
So, a couple of things here,
the last few months for the
Ukrainians have been mostly, as
you mentioned, the holding
ground against the Russian
spring offensive.
, But part of bakhmut, where
else are the Russian forces
making any serious effort to
turn forward?
Is there anywhere?
>> I mean the short answer is,
they are.
Not they are continuing to sort
of engage in localized movement
in kherson.
And that is about it.
So, you, know that really
raises the question of what is
going on behind those lines.
It brings up the questions that
we've been looking at for
months now.
Which is the capacity of
Russian officers to plan
offensive operations, at all.
And, the morale of Russian
soldiers to execute on those
offensive operations.
And, it's not at all clear that
they're able to do either.
>>, And just very quickly, once
those weapons arrive and you
have newly-chain troops back in
country, is this shutting off
to be a possible route of the
Russians by the Ukrainians?
>> I wouldn't call it a route.
The Russians have too much mass,
?
Right too many men, too much
material to be grounded.
The turning point in this, more
into the next phase of this war,
is the ability of the Ukrainian
armed forces to engage in
combined arm ammunition.
It is to say to fight like nato
fights.
To fight like the west fights.
To fight palmer position of
having superior tactics and
superior operational planning.
And the operational strategic
level.
To make the exploits with fewer
weapons but with better trained
men and better weapons to
achieve those operational
outcomes that they're trying